hola su majestad o lo que puedo hacer
por usted
problema matemático de qué se trata
bueno sé que tengo como las azul 1 2 3 4
5 ok eso suena razonable si puedo ver
que tienes incómodas azules eso es
correcto aquí hay 5 moras azules y cuál
es el problema bueno también tengo
si veo que también tiene tres cerezas
lo que yo quiero saber es el total de
piezas de fruta que tengo y no sé si
tengo que tomar 5 y sumar 3 o tomar 5 y
restar 3 entiendo que tengo que hacer
algo con el 5 y con el 3 pero no sé
necesito que me ayudes ok reina cálmense
nuestros amigos que están aquí nos
pueden ayudar hay que dejarlos que pasen
el vídeo y que piensen en esto y nos
ayuden sabemos que tenemos 5 moras
azules y 3 cerezas así que la pregunta
es si queremos calcular el total de
piezas de fruta que tenemos debemos
tomar 5 moras azules 5 moras azules y
sumarle 3 cerezas o debemos tomar 5
moras azules 5 moras azules y restar 3
cerezas entonces vamos a dejar que
nuestros amigos pausa en el vídeo y que
traten de pensar cuál de estas
operaciones describe la situación que la
reina quiere resolver
qué pausa en el bebé
tengo ok bueno asumo que ya pensaron en
esto cuando sumamos algo vamos a
incrementar la cantidad de fruta y si
empezamos con 5
vamos a incrementar esta cantidad en 3
si van a restar eso significa que van a
quitar moras azules que van a quitar
algunas piezas de fruta entonces la
situación que estamos describiendo es 5
+ 3 si hiciéramos 5 menos 3
eso significa que empezamos con 5 moras
azules y dejen de poner aquí abajo 5
moras azules las voy a copiar y pegar
voy a copiar sin comunas azules ok
aquí están mis 5 moras y quiero quitar
tres así que quitamos una dos tres
cuando sumo
tengo y me las quito es que estoy
haciendo una
esta lista
para saber el número total de piezas de
fruta que tengo así es 5 3 vamos a ver
aquí tenemos 5 6 7 y 8 el total de
frutas es 8
un poco de la resta quiere
a ver cuántos 5 -3 ok aquí lo tenemos
empezamos con 5 y quitamos 3 1 2 3 y nos
quedan estas 2 que tenemos aquí una y
dos moras azules así que 5 menos 3 es
igual a 2
esto es nada
qué bueno que pude ayudar